hey everybody it's brian here for
awesome comics and i got a couple of
really special guests for us today it's
guy i got scott snyder and greg capullo
artist and writer of batman in DC now i
just want to ask you guys you guys have
been doing about 50 issues 50 issues
going to be your last one so I know it's
a labor of love for you guys I know you
guys put a lot of your heart and soul in
your writing I can tell that you really
get the character and in your art I can
really see that you just really love
drawing Batman and how he fights and
reacts and all that stuff so what was
the hardest thing about Batman to write
and draw for you throughout the entire
series well I think for me the hardest
thing was the intimidation factor I mean
Batman he has 75 years of amazing
stories creators that I've looked up to
for my whole life like I've worked on
this character and done stories that are
far better than I could do so when you
get the job you know I remember being
like to my wife maybe I should just like
call in sick for the whole year forever
you know and and what the hardest thing
is owning it where you realize like
everybody that you love that did Batman
made their own version of Batman their
own version of Bruce that corresponded
to their their passions their worries
their time like they're at their moment
and for me it was about understanding
that i had to do that too and having a
partner like him it was so supportive
made that really possible i feel like
from go and I'm very proud of kind of
how our Batman is very much ours like
it's different than grants or Denny
O'Neill's or everything and I love those
so much but I read ours and I see his
and I'm like that's our Batman you know
you know with anything you know you got
to try and separate yourself from the
rest of the pack even if it's in a
subtle small way and so many Batman
Tarzan they've all been great but and
even though I inherited Jim Lee's
designs when he took over 52 you know I
still tried to modify it to make it a
bit more my way and and then certainly
when I got 20 year and I got to redesign
a costume and now again and 50 now it's
completely my way but um one of the
things would like Batman okay we all
know he's great martial artists and
everything and I know a bit about
martial arts myself in dead and I
certainly have done a few martial art
kind of
moves for Batman in the book but they
don't really don't translate that well
in comics where's brawling kind of
movements translate with a lot more
impact so even though he's a technical
fighter if you look at a lot of my plate
teens a lot of it some big brawling you
know haymakers because that just
translates better than very cuts sharp
defined moves you know that was a great
on film you know a little tougher to
really pull that off you know so mainly
doing that and as I said with the new
costume you know I've always tried to
make my boot Bruce more more heavy limbs
and less ripped to the bone kind of like
a lot of guys do that spray painted on
suit you know I always hate that every
hero looks like that Batman I think
looks more dangerous heavier you know
just a little more heavier I'm
pre-contest bodybuilder Batman you know
and a lot less features on the mass none
of that furrowed brow and stuff I try
and keep that to the barest minimum
because you know I mean it's like the
less features to me is again more
intimidating you know I think I'm back
to like a movie you may may not know
cool hand luke and they had the one guy
walked the line all time you never saw
his eyes man it's just all mere mere
glasses that made it scary and I mean so
let's feature is better you don't
exactly know what's in the cat's head
you know so that's the way I tried to
treat my guy you know that's my favorite
movie you know that right I might show
up love it drinking it up your boss I
can eat 50 eggs Lucille oh that dress is
so tight I swear I see a seam busts
loose quit working us up you're talking
about issue 50 now that's the last last
issue for you guys what do you guys feel
about exiting oh yeah oh okay oh thank
you thank you next um so how do you guys
feel exiting Batman and like what do you
think about just like going on a new new
avenues new projects and stuff like that
how do you feel about it well I mean for
me I think you know I'm gonna continue
to do some bad stuff that's a little bit
different like I feel like Batman
working on Batman is always
and Greg I wouldn't keep on the title or
stay on the title without him it'll
always be us if I ever do Batman but I
have some stories I wanted to do and I
have some you know fun things and we'll
announce it soon but ultimately for me I
mean I feel like the same way he does
about you know getting off the title in
some ways after we've done a lot that we
could do and the book is still doing
really well and and hopefully it makes
people more excited when we come back
together after he does his projects and
I work on this stuff and you know any
time he says I'm free to do anything
whether it was creator-owned or DC or
marvel I'd be there in a second like
there's nobody I'd work with above this
guy ever in my life so you know as a
friend and as a as a partner so I'm sure
it's like for me it's not really sad
because it feels like oh we're just
gonna go to the next thing soon and work
on something else soon and you know so
yeah with me you know i think we're
stepping off at a good time you know we
were still bringing the heat and you
know certainly I wasn't feeling like I
was burnout on the character or anything
like that but you don't want to get to
that point were you starting to feel you
know my legs are starting to go you know
but you know because we've all seen it
in like television shows everything else
where you know they're right and I and
they and they just keep running it until
it just sinks you know until
cancellation I just think that's like
the worst thing you know it's like when
I was throwing up there's a show all in
the family and they did that and it was
a great show in the beginning and they
just count milking that cow until it was
dead on the ground you know and we're a
Seinfeld you know they left when
everybody still was loving the show and
you go they wanted him back so I think
we're doing the right thing in the fact
that we can always at some point revisit
Batman so we recharge we're way from it
we take a little breath of air and if we
go back we come back strong we never got
to the point where fans are going Jesus
Christ can't wait for that team they get
the hell off the book and I think so so
I know you guys are doing some new stuff
now I think Greg you're gonna go work
with Mark malhar what do you guys say
about that uh well I can't see too much
until he says what he wants to say about
it but I will just say that it's with
all the stuff I've done you know whether
it was quasar x-force you know
on spawn Batman it is different than
anything I've ever done in my
professional career as far as subject
matter and the kind of things i'll be
drawn so I'm looking forward to building
these worlds you know and and I'm
inspired by it and I can't wait and i
hope it does well on the big screen so
that i can make a whole lot of money you
know cuz we all love a whole lot of
money even if you don't worship money a
whole lot of money it's a very good
thing so hoping for a whole lot of money
and i would say also like knowing what I
know about the project and knowing what
I know about mark what a good guy is
what a great writer and this guy it's
gonna be some amazing you know I'm
really excited for them both and be
first in line you know to cheer the
button so now there have been rumors
that you might be going to Justice
League any validity there anything you
can comment on that no no I'm not doing
justice league I can't do I can't do a
double ship really for me I'd love to do
justice league with him like if we went
if I did justice league i would do like
a set story that we got a head on and
didn't have to do like the grind we did
on Batman and I would work on it with
him like he's you know that's the
graduation I feel like would be fun but
for doing a double shift Justice League
I don't want to do double Batman
either and it's nothing against like the
people doing those books or DC I think
they could be great you know I just I
have two kids I teach for DC I teach a
class that i adore about bringing in new
writers new voices and they hired me
also as a creative consultant so my my
workload is such that it's just doing a
double ship after the run that we had on
Batman or even on Justice League it
wouldn't be the right thing so I have a
book coming I'm very excited about
announcing next week that's a monthly
that allows me to do Batman stories in a
different way than I've done them before
so I can't wait to see that now last
thing for you guys real quick uh for
Batman what was your favorite part that
you guys did throughout the entire
series was the best thing for you to do
like that it's just awesome what was it
for you guys yeah I I you know we did a
lot of fun stuff and great stuff that
you know both of those are proud of but
for me I think probably issue 5 where we
rotated the issue around full circle and
disoriented the fans to go along with
Batman's being disoriented I I think
that was probably the coolest thing we
did
I agree that was also one of the first
times we really stuck up for each other
against DC or did something that made me
feel like we were a team you know doing
something that like we both believed and
they might not have believed in and it
really meant a lot you know so i love
that moment to thank you guys so much
for talking oh yeah I had a really good
time talk to you guys we can't we look
forward to everything that you guys got
coming so thank you very much I'm Brian
ya round the corner alright a Brian with
Action Comics awesome comic seasick he
knows it he knows it just talk to him